in Game of Thrones Season seven we
learned that Jon Snow's real name is
Aegon Targaryen he's the son of Rhaegar
Targaryen
which means Daenerys is John's aunt yes
John has sex with his aunt
Rhaegar dead now so is Viserys Targaryen
and Aerys and Aemon Targaryen in the
books they're still Bloodraven Targaryen
bastard and young Griff who claims to be
tug Aryan but Brendan's a tree and Griff
might be fake go watch those videos so
really Daenerys and John are the last
Targaryen
last of the dynasty that ruled Westeros
for centuries and last of the
Dragonlords of Illyria Valyria was an
empire that ruled half the world for
thousands of years until 400 years ago
it exploded
this was the doom of Valyria and it's a
mystery connecting to magic faceless men
Lannister gold and the legacy of
Daenerys and John's family so Valyria
was a peninsula to the east of Westeros
thousands of years ago the Valyrians
were shepherds among volcanic mountains
called the 14 flames until they
discovered dragons and trained them as
weapons of war at the time the area was
dominated by a gase by old case an
empire built on slavery so the Valyrians
and their dragons conquered the ghiscari
and took them as their own slaves the
Valerians expanded building an empire
across most of the known world they
called themselves the freehold because
all landowners had a say in government
but wherever they conquered the freehold
took slaves sending thousands down the
14 flames to mine for gold and silver
Valyria had advanced technology and
magic they used dragon flame to shape
stone into beautiful towers they made
Valyrian steel swords long roads and
colonies fill areas like ancient Rome
just with dragons and with incest and
the Dragonlords traditionally married
their own siblings they believed they
were descended from dragons and wanted
to keep their blood pure the Dragonlords
lived in the capital city of Valyria
using magic and politics in an endless
struggle for power and glory
Valyria was the center of civilization
until the doom came every Hill in
Valyria erupted with fire smoke and lava
so hot that Dragons were burned from the
sky the earth cracked open and swallowed
whole town's Lakes boiled and the sea
flooded in the clouds rained obsidian
and black blood within hours the whole
Peninsula was shattered the Empire gone
all Valeria's knowledge and technology
like how to make Valyrian steel who was
lost the only dragon Lords to survive
this doom with a Targaryen who had left
Valyria years earlier because de nies
Targaryen foresaw the doom in a dream so
these Targaryen 's the ancestors of
Daenerys and John settled on Dragonstone
and would later conquer Westeros now 400
years after the doom Valyria is a
smoking ruin a cursed and demon haunted
in the show Tyrion and Jorah visit the
ruins and survived but in the books no
one returns from Valyria whole fleets
and armies have disappeared there
including Tyrians uncle Gary and
Lannister euron greyjoy claims to have
been there but he might be lying whether
the danger is demons or toxic volcanic
fumes the place is dangerous the doom
still rules Valyria but what was the
doom and what caused it the doom might
have been a natural volcanic eruption
author George modern compared the doom
to the eruption of krakatoa and the fall
of Pompeii
but Valyria pieces involved magic
Valyria is a place of fire magic and
it's got dragons and volcanoes it's
called the lands of the long summer
compare that with far north Westeros
called the lands of always winter which
has White Walkers and ice magic these
two places seem like centers of Ice and
Fire in this world maybe they're
connected to the irregular seasons the
North had an icy disaster in the long
night and Valyria had a fiery disaster
in the doom and this affected the
world's magic when the doom fell on
Valyria magic died in the West and it's
only recently returning
so the point is that Valyria had some
serious cosmic elemental magic happening
and the Valyrians [ __ ] with it the
Valyrians were sorcerers and for
thousands of years they used spells to
tame the fourteen flames but at the same
time they mined the flames for gold and
silver
these were volcanoes full of magma and
fire worms and slaves were killed by the
hundreds and yet they kept mining deeper
and deeper like some cazador [ __ ] in
Lord of the Rings the dwarves of Moria
delved too greedily and too deep and
they awoke the fiery Balrog maybe
Valyrian is similar they got too greedy
dealt too deep and set off the fourteen
flames because that's what happens when
you mess with magic in this world
we're told over and over that magic is
dangerous with illyrians in their
arrogance thought they could control
magic but it blew up in their face so
now their ruins stand like Ozymandias or
atlantis a warning against hubris and
the mining of magic volcanoes but
there's still more to the story
in book four irons the faceless men a
cult of assassins who worship death
she's trained by the kindly man who
tells her that the faceless men began in
Valyria among the slaves who mined in
the fourteen flames
he says the slaves suffered so badly in
the mines that they wished for death
the first faceless man gave the gift of
death to a slave aya argues that the man
should have killed the Valyrian slave
masters instead and he replies that the
faceless would bring the gift to them as
well but that is a tale for another day
so this is a hint that the faceless men
caused the doom of Valyria which makes
sense the men arose from Valyrian slaves
and they're now based in Braavos which
was founded by ex slaves escaping
Valyria and the faceless men worship
death so killing thousands in a doom is
probably their idea of a good time but
how could the faceless cause the doom
one theory is that they used dragon eggs
at summer Hall it seems that dragon eggs
caused a deadly fire maybe the faceless
used lots of eggs to
the 14 flames but there's another
possibility that ties in to a prophecy
the world book says the Valyrian
sorcerers foretold that the gold of
Casterly Rock would destroy them
Casterly Rock is home to the Lannisters
who were famous for their gold mines
even in Valyrian times but for some
reason the Valyrians never contacted the
rich Lannisters even though they were so
hungry for gold that they were mining
volcanoes maybe the Valyrians avoided
the Lannisters because of this prophecy
but the Lannisters back then really
wanted a Valyrian steel sword all the
cool Westerosi families had one lakh
Starks ice and tarly's heart's pain so
in the century before the doom the
Lannisters bought the Valyrian sword
bright roar for a huge amount of gold we
don't know who sold bright roar to the
Lannisters but if this gold went to
Valyria it could have fulfilled the
prophecy of Illyria's destruction how
could gold cause the doom the great
families of Valyria were in constant
conflict sometimes they assassinated
each other which was a problem because
some of these Valyrians were sorcerers
who spells held back the 14 flames the
world book suggests that too many of
these sorcerers were assassinated so the
spells failed and that's why the doom
happened maybe these assassinations were
carried out by the assassins of the
faceless men the faceless men don't kill
for free they charge a high price so
maybe they were paid with that Lannister
gold that a Valyrian got by selling
bright raw so the Valyrians were so
caught up in their petty political
conflicts that they paid for their own
destruction
giving prophecy gold to the death cult
that arose from their own slavery and
oppression as Tyrion says Valyria was
built on blood and fire and they raped
what they disowned so that theory brings
together all the hints from the text
Lannister gold paid for faceless
assassinations the destabilized magic
and caused the doom but you can add some
tin foil on top because it may be that
the Valerians ordered these
assassinations not knowing that there
cause the doom but maybe it was
deliberate maybe one of these warring
families wanted to wipe out the
competition and be the Last Dragon Lord
standing we know the Targaryen were a
fairly minor house in Valyria when they
left for Dragonstone their rivals
thought them cowards but maybe the
Targaryen x' ordered these
assassinations to cause the doom to
destroy their enemies they made up some
excuse about a dream and went to
Dragonstone and watched their own
homeland burn leaving them the only
dragon Lords in the world free to become
the unopposed rulers of whatever realm
they chose maybe House Targaryen
Daenerys and John's family is founded on
a terrible genocide all betrayal but
that's just speculation whatever caused
the doom Valyria has lessons for its
descendants Daenerys and John because
the Valyrians were kinda [ __ ] they
seem to think that just cuz they were
magic and pretty they could enslave the
world they conquered peaceful peoples
and worked thousands of slaves to death
with their theories of racial
superiority
they are basically Nazis with dragons so
when they destroyed themselves with
their own fire and blood it's kind of
hard to feel sorry for them Valyrian
blood gives Dany and John the power of
dragons magic and prophecy but the ruins
of Valyria should remind them to use
their power with humility and compassion
the doom of Valyria destroyed a whole
civilizations knowledge skills like the
forging of Valyrian steel were lost
forever but luckily our world's
knowledge and skills are available on
Skillshare Skillshare is an online
learning site with thousands of classes
in design business writing and forging
steel so if you want your own family
sword
check out this course we've used
Skillshare to learn some After Effects
techniques and they've got some really
high quality courses if you want to
learn how to start a business edit video
produce music or found a continent
spanning Empire of blood and Fire sign
up for Skillshare today get a 2 month
free trial at the link below thank you
to history of Westeros for some
scripting help and thanks to the page
including Zack Whiteman thorny Eckstrom
Ganon McDonald Lesley Machado Tristan
Szabo Natasha Lee and says e Besh Cheers
you